you're on come over my place tomorrow I
have to go meet my future stepbrother
just cover me try to be nice then he's
oh no that's shadi that's the sponsor so
Erica you must be psyched to have a
older brother type in the house
totally psyche you have to have a
complete stranger living in my home
really want to punch you in the face
right now I just don't want to ruin
those lip injections that daddy gave you
at least my daddy is not in jail looks a
complicated little guy you've accused a
teacher of fondling him thinks he saw
him around town shaking down a child
molester is our moral obligation
nobody's going anywhere until we see
this guy Melissa money I don't think he
will he's like a pro that's what you get
like a subterranean dungeon for totally
oh do I know you I'm sorry bowling alley
you're hot old guy me my friends you've
been hogging your goodies for like the
last six months my goodies yeah oh my
god okay so what's the plan what if we
break in and tie him up
yeah Dom in like he's our a little [ __ ]
surprise I'm not stalking you or
anything as you can tell I have like
made
daddy issue where were you last night
with my friends doing what a little bit
up you get in no I'm sure find the right
filter buying tampons like what's it to
you
what just happened
or vigilantes Cheers
okay no I'm obviously not okay are you
guys going to go buy some crack you know
throw down it's okay they're not buying
drugs Bob I get the joke
you